[Music]
[Applause]
hello everybody
varalu how's it going uh good morning
and happy Monday Persia here
Jordan is joining us today and we are
playing at kill like hell yes it's
pretty straightforward but when it comes
to enemy I feel like I can never beat
you like correct
I get like severe anxiety but anywho
yeah this game just came out not too
long ago Friday
this past Friday yeah so it came out the
same day as Wolfenstein and competition
when it came up yeah exactly a lots of
awesome meetings coming out right now
but yeah I felt like with everything
going on this one's gotten a little bit
less attention so we're here to play it
and check it out today so yeah we have
story mode versus mode practice mode all
the things you need in a fighting game
because this is you know technically a
fighting game I say technically because
it's like an arena fighter yeah so it's
a little bit different than you know
maybe like a 2d or a 3d freighter like
you know if what Evo is coming up this
weekend for those of you who like watch
my names like that but arena fighters
are cool
and lately I kind of noticed a lot of
anime yeah yeah Kali tam and I have been
pushing for more anime stuff games and
covers on the site so it was very happy
when Kali allowed me to review this game
right now on the website if you guys
want to check that out along with some
cool videos where we already have like
all the Super's and specials or stuff
like that yeah and stuff like that in
fighting games exactly so shout outs to
max it's hard work who will also be at
Evo so yes this is an arena fighter and
something on top of the fact that it's
based off with this enemy is that
there's also a new story blood yes
illness which is interesting so the
whole point of this game
so normally Rico is pictured right here
is the protagonist of killa kill this
game asks
what if story that's where the F comes
if Watsky was the protagonist of killa
kill so this actually starts a little
bit into the anime so okay so not like
right from the beginning starts we round
up for episode 5 somewhere around there
so for a quick refresher for people who
don't know what killer kill is or who
haven't watched in a very long time the
basic gist of the entire thing is that
Yuko right here her father is killed and
the only clue she has to his murderers
identity is half of a giant scissor that
was used to kill him and she goes
traveling from one high school to the
next in search of who possibly could
have police to the killer's identity and
when she finally gets to honno-ji
Academy it's ruled by the fascist leader
Satsuki who kind of rules the school
with like an iron fist and her school
uses these special uniforms that allow
people to gain special abilities and
powers and she recognizes this is her
blade through cos like oh you must know
who the killer is but zosky doesn't want
to tell her anything and her underlings
just destroy ryuko effortlessly so ryuko
retreats she goes off somewhere else and
she finds this black sailor uniform that
is sentient and in exchange for feeding
on her blood it transforms rico into a
magical girl that allows her to hold her
own against the students of anoche
academy and then she decides to
challenge the entire student body and
that's what anime is it's very
convoluted this story picks up where you
canõt has sent ketsu and she's trying to
vie for a spot on the student council by
beating sots keys elite for the four
students these two and these two okay so
now I like to be honest I've never seen
this anime before it's a lot a little
bit of the back story goes a long way
especially to see how it fits in as like
a fighting game so yeah I say we hop
into some of the story mode
because I think it's interesting that
they have like a story plot oh yeah you
might be continuing I might be and I was
recently had the English dub on because
I was listening to the English dub voice
actors and the special stuff they had to
say I assume people want to hear this in
the original Japanese so we can play
through the story from sakis perspective
or from Yukos so I assume people wanted
to see Satsuki because this is her
stories a little start with this yeah I
feel like when it comes to anime in
general like you can't even like you
can't even like have a short description
of what it's about it's just impossible
but yeah so some of the other like
animes I have been getting arena
fighters like my hero and you know there
was jump for I feel like they like kinda
stick to the story like when I play once
justice it was like I was watching the
anime all over again
so I think it's interesting if there's
like something new oh here maybe I
should turn this up a little bit a tiny
bit killer killer also has very very
gently and they've included a lot of the
soundtrack game so like the song playing
right now is one of my favorite
animation yeah they even I've liked a
gallery and stuff where you can go in
eighteen plus on this to you just
because
kill the kill does this like weird thing
where everything about it is like a pun
or like building off of something it
likes to make fun of certain like anime
perspectives and things like that in one
of the excessive sexual fanservice and
anime is definitely one of those things
that they acknowledge I was snap been in
the chat yeah I love no none she's so
cute
I've always enjoyed the antenna theory
it's like all you needs to get the point
across
folks this chemistry again I realized
the cameras right over the subtitles
everyone watching in BO units under each
the whole thing each other it's good no
they're not Geo
not another on it Connie knows it they
like their big blocky resume we go oh no
I got to go Daddy Kuwait have another
day or night my vet CeCe
all night that's existing you're never
gonna know geo sprout each get out of a
hundred
not that I see cockpit what are you oh
no she got trained oh hi how are you so
epic
it can't be an anime game without an
excessive amount of Pepsi yes
[Music]
all right I think for the moment it's
safe to bring us back
[Music]
and this is like
to give you a better idea of what its
art style is like yeah it looks really
good
[Music]
you that battle armor
I'm kind of disappointed they use
is all the armor can deflect really
in the armor late
[Music]
it's always gonna be the one super cute
and like adorable character
and then they're like low-key super
you're like often yeah this describe you
is very well
[Music]
like they put it enough you know of the
costume in all the areas that there's a
Kotak says this game is awesome and
eschew minami-chan the entity enjoy it
well have you been enjoying it because I
know you've been playing I say in my
review I describe it as this is probably
not a good fighting game mechanically
it's not like the best fighting game but
as a killer kill game it is excellent it
captures the wild I will never lose my
way Barry
but I've seen it super slow saved over a
few missus a terminal the star system
basically describes how powerful a
uniform is so one is week two is pretty
good and three is like God like he's got
like he has three on his solder
where's the logic there is no logic
logic don't you know you know Matthew I
do also enjoy the job for a Killa Killa
this one's a new anime is that I
actually will go back and forth between
watching it and sub and Doug yeah I like
heard my hair for the first time
language Japanese I was like slow
tonight
it just sounds weird it comes off
there's the dog I know I watched like
seven deadly sins and dubbed though and
I loved that are you comment about this
- no study no smoking a tentative
I've enjoyed much of excessive games
[Music]
and she's not even in her like hey
alka G has does not provide enough out
but soon the little tails
it's tasty you can interrogate us almost
a license or think you know my mother so
Casa Febus our she
this is kind of a moment where like the
story would diverge if we were playing
Rico story we would have to fight all
four of them in a row on one health bar
but since we're not playing as Ryoga we
just watched the fight pathway that's so
cool though that they give you like both
perspectives and they're different
enough not to replay value my arrow
semester dangling the information is it
time is it time to finally battle
[Music]
oh my god oh my god
Tuscany even new data yuck techniques
you
[Music]
tell you what I mean Danny got 13 a
Yakima Matamoros oh here he's thirsty oh
[Music]
dang it sucks keys mom
oh shoot a fool no more use your yappy
gossamer go stick your correct they were
all legit nude in the anime like if this
is the tone down congee no Jim Beam of a
solicitor helm on who the enemy itself
puzzle with almost 24 episodes plus a
twenty-fifth you should check out this
anime it's only like three hundred
episodes long I'm like
Matthew is here all right yes let's
fight
I'm excited you receive like the
anticipation is building so I think
after seeing the intro scenes here if we
can we'll just skip the rest so the
people at home can watch and not be
spoiled Nancy Jordans awesome gameplay
and yeah
the main mechanics yogurt close-range
attack which gave you a horizontal and
vertical series of aerial attacks longer
attacks and guard
they're very obvious when he encountered
it with his name
[Music]
okay and you can opt out that our
follow-up
zeliha powder super yeah if he manages
to hit me with it she does the movie
from the anime right just like tapper
and she goes flying
[Music]
easy easy
so how would you say that characters are
when it comes to like their fighting
style on how like it reflects them in
the anime I think they'd do a really
good job there I wish that there were
more characters but the characters what
they do have they do a very good job of
reflecting them from the anime like I'm
a gory who's a masochist he's getting
stronger the more damage that he takes
and he connects the image on himself not
gonna go missing I guess she made
everyone fighter they all got bodied and
then she's like all right let me do it
to kind of give everyone a better idea
of the fighting and probably stop doing
the story do that but Emil has online
it's alright
sorry Jim be a total no he musta changed
Santos a at Sugar Creek Oona Deema soon
keep vomiting okay so
and we as obtaining some points
ranked match Oh do it do it do a big
batch should have brought another
control I know I should've I you know I
don't know why I didn't anticipate the
long cutscene when I was like yeah we
could play through the story modes oh
wait we have some options that we can
play us is the chat have any suggestions
but recommendations a fight again and
maybe I'll convince during the play some
online matches if you guys wanna hop in
see how that goes but yeah let us know
what character it was like check out I
kind of want to see the character Olli
unless doing yeah okay she looks
adorable
[Music]
this one first and then look by taking
y'all's forklift for who you guys yoga
[Music]
got a mock oh request ma KO is free dlc
but she is not out yet i'm eager eager
li awaiting her oh man this crazy is
like games just drop with dlc plan off
the bat like every game now which is
like cool but it's such a standard
[Music]
eg monogamy
I've never done well facing up against
rocky ugh she has this stupid life
watching
[Music]
she makes good she make herself yeah
made out of fiber
[Music]
oh cool the DLC is getting word from
chato few DLC is free which is awesome
I'm always a fan of free big free DLC
right if it's free then it's for me
cute the hair always gives me if your
hair's always ginormous enemy hair is
just it defies gravity it's amazing
[Music]
I like when people cosplay certain anime
characters have crazy hair and they nail
it I'm like yeah that's a really good
job like tell by the hair
oh those combos
for a computer
[Music]
Oh
yes this enemy don't have that many
episodes I'm probably going to check it
out you should it's so good it feels a
lot less daunting to be like watch 24
episodes there's like 200 so it's pretty
like short to like episodes in general
they're like 25 minutes but you know
whenever you play against people in
fighting games in their leg yeah good
games you did really well but you lost
and like deep down I'm just like then on
the outsider like you alright so we did
get some requests slicing we did
ryuko and regalia let's say the regalia
is the name of what most of the uniforms
that people were like the pro regalia
and the skirt regalia so I can face off
against one of the people who wear a
regalia
[Music]
oh and he says on Netflix that's good
good that can definitely watch it now
so against really annoying version of
this character he just spams long-range
attacks oh boy
what up crime scourge
alright so gamma gory
now there's a little bit of a stream
delay in going so if we like picture ker
and then you ask for one we'll put it in
the queue hey new girl the disrespect
I can't imagine the views out 15 that
comes your boy here this looks like a
wedgie Anaheim it probably is take some
getting used to I'm sure I guess when
you're running away from like people
with giant swords and marching band
magic it's kind of it's gonna hurt us
pay attention for ready
[Music]
Oh
sorry now she's fighting with Bolthouse
yeah so I can only assume she eventually
finds the other half she does eventually
find the other half of this is there I
can't look at so there's the same way
anymore after watching us I made the
mistake of staying away from her dang it
she's gonna keep spam you know you're in
there
seelix says my biggest turnoff is the
camera because I can't follow and judge
my position yeah that's something really
interesting to me about arena fighters
is that you know in other fighting games
you're very clearly like on player one
side or play or to side or and like
arena fighters it's like you're either
close to the camera or you're far away
that's pretty much how it's gonna be
[Music]
so graceful she wanted to get away oh my
god Dragonball Fighters is not an arena
fighter it's not that's what I wanted
though for this killer kill game for it
to be a that's kind of what I wanted out
of like kind of a lot of arena fighters
actually like a 2d TD game because
especially as like a Marvel players
specifically Marvel 3 like I enjoy that
art styles but like school girls also
that you know line art style much like
more appealing to me personally then
like the 3d is the 3d effects use the
big guys so somebody someone else also
requested a matchup earlier I don't know
if that's the one you're going for
scratch and ski skirt regalia is worn by
gamma gory and we're facing off against
that ski noise
$500 seems a little excessive name the
collector's edition is $500 I almost use
this guy as the guy for the thumbnail
there is a really cool shot of him
sometimes I wonder like if in the future
this stuff was real that'd be so freaky
to watch like find the spikes it's made
a little bit weirder when you realize
that gum Liguori purposely held himself
back so that he would be in the same
grade as sure it's a he's 20 years old
oh my goodness
like nemesis obscure move really fast
well I want the belly-flop work
[Laughter]
being damaged I get stronger when I take
damage so I was whipping myself it makes
sense that's what I like about like
anime fighting games is that they're
like super true to their characters it's
like even in jump [__] what's his name
like after used to super ability he like
leaves he never comes back to fight
because like that's what he does yeah I
don't remember his name
that's Aegon evolves into like his
evolved form right with the long pointy
hair yeah and then he doesn't like super
super ability and then if you use it
like mid game he's just you can't use
them anymore you just leave the scene
and like never comes back and like
somebody else you like can't hit the
girl characters so you just like throws
hearts at them and said oh yeah adorable
awesome alright we're gonna rock paper
scissors this I have no help
did you win I did
nice I like could not tell it like
there's a lot going on right now so it's
like a clash and then you guys have to
pick with yeah you know it's like so in
Soul Calibur they have something kind of
like that also anyone so this game for
those asking is available on Nintendo
switch ps4 and PC so if you want to try
it on any one of those go for it I'm
taking a look online to see if it's on
Xbox as well but it's definitely on
those straight platforms
yeah I'm trying to see if it's offline
xbox outlast laugh it's not ok ok it is
an ass on Xbox only which we can try
online it's yes let's do it let's try it
who has this game as well we're on ps4
so if you haven't you should hop online
try to hop into a match with us I'm
reminded of how bad I am at fighting
games whatever I mean it is what it is I
feel like whenever I play online it's
either night and day it's either I
fighting in somebody who completely
squashes me or I just completely destroy
somebody else there's never an
in-between alright let's do this I would
you have to pick your character before
you go into the room yeah
oh yeah this did just come out July 25th
you guys so four short days go and DLC
is on the way so that's also something
to look forward to
obviously we have online battles
training mode story mode let's see if
anyone has already created a room
somewhere online let's see we'll give it
a few moments oh nice do it
we found a room I feel like that's rare
sometimes in fighting games like you go
to like search for lobbies and you
actually see a lobby compared to like
just searching him no it was scared he
was shook he didn't want none maybe he
was also worried as I was when he saw
that we were rocking like the same
colored outfit and hairstyle it's like
oh this is about to be so confusing like
heck no all right let's discuss search
for a match you got to climb the rink
straighten the number one on the
leaderboard if they have those actually
names to be a fighting game I always
want to hit this as the select but
that's missing it's the back button so
what happens when you play on too many
consoles
yes nice that was fast
all right see this is great I feel it in
every like five you're giving me like
you don't want to play online at all
you're like god I don't want to oil it
was one of those things I was doing very
well in online this weekend for like the
first few days and then it got to the
point like Oh people have now gotten the
game and their games really good and I
just started not doing well all right so
she's using dual blade so she's a bit
faster but not as strong okay so each
character has like different variations
oh nice
[Music]
all right
first ring to match let's go Tori then
you got this
[Music]
good
go ahead it's hard game has no counter
system
[Music]
oh man
the combos
[Music]
whoof
the controller vibration oh dang oh dang
I like the slow-mo black-and-white at
the end - it was like dang those combos
were fancy mm-hmm she's incredibly fast
I think her and the dude and the green
he has the two fastest combos like
what's the right word fast it's like and
so it's like one of those things that
they can get into their combo it's very
very difficult okay okay
Mike counter them about to say max even
has on our site that the character that
we just bought she has a combo that if
she can land it just destroys an entire
health bar yeah I did see you liked some
of the combos in that video and I was
like holy schmow crazy oh oh that's good
oh dang
oh my goodness could be
yeah I think that's actually has combos
with every character right yeah yeah
guys so if you're interested and
learning this game and you need a place
to start
max definitely put together video with
some combos with every single character
it's up on gamespot.com right now so
check that out we're getting the a taste
of what some of these problems look like
especially the last game this game ooh
Oh some of the people in the chat are
saying there are some there are counters
of countering system there is a counter
you can just use it so rarely that it's
easy to juggle people if their counter
is not ready yeah it's the same bar that
you use for your special like that I CSU
Soup says rings match it ring makes this
look like a completely different game
yeah that's usually the case when it
comes to fighting games like you can't
really get a good grasp of like how the
game fights in story mode because they
want you to like you know obviously
fight a specific way when it comes to
the story but in you know rings you get
to see what people have been doing with
the game how they've been like breaking
the game finding combos in tech and
instead of which I know from like
traditional fighting games when it comes
to arena fighter is definitely not my
ballpark I know like 1% of things I
should probably know about arena
fighters few hilarious s countdown the
screen every few seconds well a counter
hit just means that you were able to
attack someone before they were able to
attacking you so you just pulled up an
attack that was faster than their attack
you are countering their heads but yes
it's different than like a burst
mechanic as a counter it's different
than jump force where someone attacks
you you can press a button at the exact
right moment and you're able to counter
their move and you can do that whenever
you want like that's actually having a
counter
what's a thread count it's essentially
your score in the rankings the higher
the thread count is the higher you Hey
looks pretty high 14:57 I think if that
was like in sheets that would be a lot
of money or you talk thread count when
you buy your sheets
all right next opponent we will see this
velvet I'm going to be facing a nun on
at some point all right yeah she seems
like the type of character where she has
a lot of people are gonna be using her
she does have those cool crazy combos
that's pretty fast
where's school girls on the switch
that's what I'm seeing Brandon then I'll
have an excuse to play it on games Maya
[Music]
we are currently playing on ps4 but it's
also available on the switch and on PC
for those wondering oh snap clash battle
the anticipation just to find out like
you won yeah I feel like if I watched
the anime this would all make a lot more
sense it's a pretty confusing animal
it's good though it's good
[Music]
nice Oh wake up super wake up / yeah
yeah oh man
like true arthéon how good are you at
our EPS in real life like regular are
yes I'm bad at a real life in terrible
if I fell like games like this I would
always be losing those clashes all the
time
[Music]
I know I know schoolgirl on mobile you
guys but we wanted on the switch there's
a difference this is scary person really
likes flashing so each character hat it
looks like they have different flash
perks like all of yours is our
additional damage but like hers she had
like get help back or exam think it's
also randomized the bed
oh it's random okay I have to now win
with the sliver of health we got this
pixel in a dream oh dang oh wow
play I thought nothing fine well it was
close to one it was good he got around
it wasn't free
hey in my mind if you get around you
didn't get you know outplayed by back
it's fine
say we can try another character as well
okay yeah guys I am going to Evo that's
this weekend woo-hoo-hoo in Las Vegas so
um yeah if you guys enjoy fighting games
you should definitely watch some Evo
this weekend Street Fighter
smash Tekken what else it isn't nice
this year yeah there's like five other
ones here they eat in so little you know
m'kay Levin's in there also there's some
other ones I'm just blinking right now
but you know it's gonna be a good time
he's one of the biggest thing in terms
of the year obviously a ton of side
tournaments I might be helping out on
the mic for a Marvel 3 side tournament
gonna be Marvel 3 salty/sweet I'm also
gonna be on a panel for women
in the FTC which is gonna be fun to a
bunch of other awesome ladies on that
panel with me that's gonna be on Friday
um so yeah you guys would be pretty
funny I should definitely check it out
or go if you can especially if you live
in Vegas like if you live in Vegas you
should definitely wait
nice I love home runs that you thank you
it's like Mega Man is even more
hilarious
[Music]
I was like that way you'll live no no
the combo just keeps going it never
entered hit into the clash yep
[Music]
using new demos
cool have your data I watched this
documentary over the weekend and
officially data has become the most
valuable resource like on the planet or
something or like yeah it's like worth
so much more money than oil now is that
crazy data has all your data it's
terrifying and also makes it very rich
the character switch is all we needed
nice get off me hold these blocks wake
up those buttons just need such
character easy what all this data
[Laughter]
it's like he's so fast and so weak but
the fact that he can go invisible is
like probably one of the cheapest and
his little blocks like tracks like they
went straight but then they would follow
a little bit towards the end which was
nice it was like kind of bumping him out
of the stuff he wanted to do just enough
to like let you do other stuff I like I
like it I say also if you like look at
him at the beginning of a match while
they're just standing staring at each
other and standing still he'll be like
doing all these poses cuboids built into
his shoulders alright next opponent
who's this loading character in the
coronary guts the dog of Maca
protagonist his best friend just typing
away he's kind of creepy like get your
data
he probably runs like background checks
before he goes on a date I used to know
someone who did that actually Lucky's
just doing all these poses so be
interesting we're both the trickster
characters cute combo oh wow so many
decoys so many decoys girls both these
blocks
[Applause]
[Music]
nice thread the needle oh my gosh pixel
in a dream shows know what to do she's
scared
let's brought that back that's all game
good we've downloaded her now she's she
shook can I throw her clones out anymore
like the blocks are coming she'll know
what to do look at it we oppression Wow
okay nice like lead right now
oh my gosh
we don't need her to hurt anymore
again yeah did you do the person who
instigates it wins they can keep going
if we win three times in a row they can
instigate an instant kill move oh gosh
finish her boom let's go Zordon running
running oh dang we got guard break so
[Music]
late for you dreaming got this you don't
know what to do you don't know what
gotta just keep up the pressure exactly
her down again
we got the life lead now Oh tickles okay
we're back okay okay we're good oh maybe
not
oh holy good she dropped it sorry break
that's been the money shot right there
coming down to the wire so close ding
that did a chunk it
now that was fun though those close one
monthly when you got this you got this
I know so close good weirdest
downloading the data starting the
analysis it's new again different color
where's Eric J eric is enjoying his life
yes a with his wife he's married now he
just got married enjoying his honeymoon
let it be let him enjoy you know
adulthood
in its finest form everyone's very happy
for him but I think everyone low key
misses him they're always like wait I've
questions oh dang this combo I say
that's the combo that max hasn't is
guarded Oh
the opponent is not responding that
combo was so good it disconnected him
from the body
yeah the combos do you like super fun
in this game switching it up new
character one that I am NOT good with
but we are going to try anyway yeah
we're gonna we're gonna play our mixtape
right now she basically has nothing good
for close range and since every other
character is like a close-range fighter
she's like at a severe disadvantage so
I'm gonna do like a lot of running away
yes gotta keep the distance you have to
own the real estate too much data to
handle just too much too many copies
there wasn't enough storage left on his
drive that was bad joke it's okay
alright here we go
new character here we go it's all about
really gonna drop the beat
nice yeah spam it up projectile city
take the music take all of it Oh
melon right through okay you don't know
the fancy combo
[Music]
name the beam beams are always cheap it
doesn't matter what kind of fighting
game it is she's cool I like you know
her kit so far all the projectiles
actually over there baited fighting in
one nice get off me over there it's like
please gotta go for that day and move
every time dancing away dancing away
please stay away please stay away she's
probably gonna be much more aggressive
this time I would be oh like a second to
leave but it's fine we know every time
she gets some space she's gonna go for
tests like that drop in the base
the beans she's so annoyed look at her
watch she's gonna dash in right after
she's so frustrated look at me feel the
music
dang it thought I could get the counter
off it does okay okay she dropped it
that was so cool
that was close that was good though
he kept dropping the column but the one
time that you did get it it was pretty
nice way yeah I kind of liked them your
character because it's like you can kind
of tell when they want to like go in cuz
they're pretty eager I like it I'm gonna
say she has this great count of if you
just press X and time she like throws
the music out at short range to stop
someone from bashing in I got it that
one I was like I just can't
timing down that's like her one
deflection for someone it comes at her
laggy hopefully
here's a chance to say no oh it's real
good
no mean what's up Otto welcome to the
stream thanks for tuning in all the way
from turkey call stage immediately that
she knows none of that okay but that'll
do gave me some ah she's wild
yes she's so bad oh oh the tree is
interesting decaffeination
[Music]
oh dang yeah that was it she's hurt in
this round
[Music]
oh my goodness wow what a conversion
holy smokes that was good went through
yeah oh my gosh every time oh dang that
combo didn't even look like a combo
alright that was rough to say the least
oh yeah but we're seeing a trend she's
very popular character online so far
she's got those fancy combos he was
actually doing a little bit different
combos is this a different variation
than the other so she's a lot stronger
but she doesn't have as many multi-hit
attack I see but she is also still very
very quick yeah I say I wish none had at
least one decent close-range attack for
the few times that someone charged in
something that's not a counter like all
of her attacks I like shoot out the
music notes and then like the music
knows like home and on someone so you
need a little bit of distance for them
to be any way shape or form effective
interesting
what is a good fighting stick to get uh
I guess I depends on your preference
really that we got a bunch of different
brands on the market right now that are
all pretty good you know
you know combi Hori big fix I have a
Horry actually the rap for which is
awesome however I did add a couple of
pounds of weight to it myself
because you know I felt like that model
was a little light so I like having the
heavier feel but I've seen their newest
model and they've you know definitely
addressed a lot of like the issues I
think in their older models so you know
these companies are actively you know
doing what they can to improve their
product and it shows like every
iteration of fighting fit that comes out
if you're like a PC player you play a
lot of PC games and stuff like that
there's a hitbox which is like all
buttons and no actual stick on the fight
stick so yeah you can press buttons for
the directional input from said I think
that's been a cool addition to the scene
a lot of players have been using it and
then of critically on pad there's ton of
flat pad players now and they're all
like winning tournaments but yes I would
say it's a matter of preference but I
think combi and horrea have been very
popular in that when Matt castles making
sticks they were a super chocolaty also
there's also razor sticks and
[Music]
there's a lot of brands nowadays how I
think about it I remember giant sorry
they were like you know very custom
arcades that company who were really
cool though because they did awesome
customization had like a clear bottom
taking like TV inside of the stick
very cool cool but if you take a look at
some of the like top not arcade sticks
that they have out now like the big fix
line which is very expensive but like
obviously very worth it maybe like
custom itching and stuff like that on
the stick yeah it's you know like cars
it's like buying car is like which ran
or which my naked model do you like the
mode oh dang like music right it feels
kind of truly names all right
practically tying it back up dancing
away dancing to stay away from me stay
away
[Music]
Oh which one's ego her I went for a
triangle to the top one did not work
Oh ding Mexico mode yo holy smokes
leave her alone just let the place of
music man it goes right through
it's like beerus like yeah no he's cool
like orb things and you know cool setups
but the super - goes right who cares
about your setup i'll see you crying
thanks for tuning in and catch you
tomorrow out some more of the cast
happy Monday you guys we got about 20
minutes left of the stream so we hope
you've been enjoying so far and it's
Monday we can't have a Monday stream
without talking about our goals right
how is your weekly goal you know nothing
too big but something to like kind of
like motivate me to work on something
throughout the week and if I get it done
like cool but if not like no big deal
cuz it's kind of small thing anyways so
my goal for this week is to practice
some Marvel 3 because I did in to the
side turn evasion evil and although I
was never like super super great at that
game I at least on a practice do not be
like super rusty that's my goal this
week before I head to Evo on Thursday
what about you Jordan make a goal a goal
for this week the goal say no to more
things I keep saying yes projects and
I'm getting very overwhelmed so much
stuff on your plate yeah that can be
tough though it's hard to like say you
know sometimes but you're right it's
important you can't get overwhelmed
that's like how you get burnt out yeah
so for your own sanity gotta do it
what about you chat what is your goal
holo anniversaries I get a job is that
your goal for the week that's a good one
that's a good always good to be employed
I should stream playing at the Evo
tournament I'm pretty sure they're gonna
have a stream there definitely from what
I've been told they're definitely in a
stream top four and I might be
commentating that so make sure you guys
tune in for that as well Pano's says is
this like those mindless button Maki
fighters or is there any balance to it
it's mostly who can press buttons faster
[Music]
I think the fun in arena fighters is the
fact that they're never balanced and
everyone she's broken and they crazy and
has all this wild stuff all the time
this guy's so slow yes and he's walking
on pigs but he's got such fast attacks
it's actually kind of cool that he's
like this crazy like dangerous like
awesome fighter but he's also online
haggling
like nothing can stop you oh snap
commander fellahin says yo I'm so happy
to see this game it is pretty cool even
from not seeing the enemy it looks cool
it looks like an enemy you've been in
gameplays
[Music]
cuz like in ones justice right it's like
the cinematics we're very like anime and
then you went to gameplay and I was like
it looked nothing nothing so this is
like you know on the other side of that
Roberto can't seem to find this game
anywhere where can i buy it it is
available on PC ps4 and Nintendo switch
so Steam PlayStation Store the Nintendo
store probably find it there it is
pretty fun despite the mashing I am
enjoying myself even though I'm wasting
a lot I am enjoying myself
that's what matters oh the pyramids
wasn't expecting a seal is I think I'm
the block what I need to remember that
oh my gosh are you like match on the
fight in the two low robots in the
middle
oh if he wants us a hard copy of this
game um I'm not sure maybe Amazon or
obviously like game Stoppers yeah that's
fine
[Music]
would be Mike
oh my goodness
[Music]
this camp is awesome he's like a giant
robot and his weapon of choice is like a
stick like what's better than that he's
a biker kid who wants to be a samurai
oh no no final round
yes commander fine when we are playing
some online battles right now Jordan is
taking on the world Omari says I love
this anime keep playing forever well we
got about 13 minutes left on the stream
but I've been watching Jordan play this
at his best for like a week I like
violin playing you and Max all right I
was watching guys play a lot
[Music]
see this is that game literally Oh
Maggie
[Music]
stop touching me
you got the livelihood right now oh my
gosh
but he's so strong he was like banging
it'll be like a three-hit combo but like
quarter your life gone like you're
trying to like teach him a lesson
come on get the combo
no okay no you're alive you're alive you
got this as close he clutched it don't
talk about Miramax he prevailed si he
says that he can see everything because
his special ability is that his eyes can
like almost tell the future based on how
someone smallest movements are so you
can actually what they're gonna do even
before they even realize that they're
going to do it so yeah he's just like
super every like Sherlock Holmes nice
except pre-emptive
now that's a pretty good treat I'm not
gonna lie okay it's actually curious
about facing a to scissor view Co to see
if she is significantly faster than that
says game would have been better if it
plays like Dragon Ball fighters we were
kind of talking about that earlier
I like we kind of wanted to see T
version but regardless I think of the
other like arena fighters I've seen
recently that's pretty good it's good
looks good and still feels very animated
oh yeah did you hear about that that
like 16 year old kid who won that
fortnight cup and 1 million dollars and
obviously I'm very very happy for him
and his parents obviously success but
damn time is like oh my goodness games
have grown so much you know I felt proud
of myself and I won like a like a local
halo tournament when I was younger at
the game crazy which was attached to my
Hollywood video you know and all I got
was like a $25 gift card and a poster
not even for a halo it was like a poster
for another game that came out really
but I was like hey they showed him like
walking up to the stage and getting his
trophy and he's like yeah he's happy of
course but if that were me I'd be laid
out on the floor in rears like
like I can't that's crazy to me I don't
even want to call him lucky because that
game you know as much as people don't
like that game I feel like that game is
hard to be good at right if you watched
a cliff of like one of the games that he
played oh snap two in a row oh I'm over
here bugging out about this party a cup
winner Jordan Jays busting ass for
Balkan hey that was actually a run back
he played that guy before I did yeah
like the first game yes
[Laughter]
but yeah like it's crazy to me that you
know game comes fire and they showed a
clip of them play I don't know if it was
the match that like solidified his win
or won a lot of the matches but it was
like last second a game and they showed
like an an outside view of like where
the two people were fighting and there's
nothing but frickin walls nothing but
walls everywhere super high up like all
the way around levels and levels and
levels and then he wins like had to
rewind the clip like five times just to
see how did you win all I see her walls
and then he shot like at a wall and I
guess the bullet like killed the wall
and then killed the person and I was
like wow that's amazing so as much as
people hate that game it's hard to be a
good at that game I mean he's a moral of
the story your parents ever tell you
you'll never be anything if you keep
playing video games all day they're
wrong at the same time I don't want to
sit here and be like hey every person
playing video games tell your parents
you're going to be a millionaire one day
because of it not that far yeah but you
know it's like definitely worth being a
game right now which is awesome it's
like geez I remember back in the day I
used to get made fun of for playing it
yeah that's cool yeah
we're not getting any more challengers
oh no you scared them off we have five
minutes left
hopefully we can get one more oh one
more yeah ask and you shall receive
maybe it's been in the office he booted
up the ps4 and bought yeah people on the
chat saying apex is harder than four at
night that's where I sucked I'm kind
fully and respectfully disagree the
reason I play apex over four at night is
because I don't have to build I find the
building aspect very difficult and
complicated and like you know sure if I
sat down in practice and got good at it
it probably wouldn't be as hard but you
know I think there's more of a learning
curve behind for tonight than there is
hiney apex all right you're in now he
was trying to keep you away
how dare you punish me from afar for the
beginning of this match oh that was like
a good side step though okay okay I'm
starting to see some of the elements
come out she looks at you with such
disappointment when the factors
oh man she's so fast she got you right
before your Pogo came out much faster
[Music]
Oh
do that again I swear are you guys going
to play tokyo ghoul 3 when it comes out
for ps4 I'm trying to convince Kali to
let me play and review all of let's also
start the petition that will mail to
college like actual email that email
Brenda Allen military she couldn't been
fair to let Dryden play all the anime
games especially when he's taking names
like space three in a row three in a row
with time for another game ooh
you know you beat that guy in like two
minutes oh it's gonna suck so fast why
have I never played us in the boy we're
playing on ps4 Clare Jagan oh yeah we
got a three win streak see if we can
keep the streak going three minutes left
this is officially the last match unless
you destroy him in like a minute then we
might have time I mean it's like I'm
pretty good
and I am facing kama Gauri oh snap
battle the big bodies the shield versus
the sword
what they call this in the kendo stick
is that correct yeah I don't know why
that was in the back of my brain
somewhere hollow says I'm pretty sure
this game is gonna be for mobile it
might translate well on mobile honestly
with the advancement in like smartphone
technology plus all the games that are
already coming to mobile I used to like
kinda think mobile gaming was wack but
now I'm kind of not against it anymore
because you know Harry Potter go came
out and I really enjoyed that I played
that for I like haven't been playing it
recently recently because I actually
just don't like walking around in public
with my phone out when Pokemon go came
out the phone I had at the time wasn't
compatible so I actually missed that
whole craze of playing pokemon gold so
playing Wizards unite and walking around
my phone out in public got me really
scared and paranoid I thought someone
was gonna try to steal it or something
so I kind of stopped playing it because
of that so yeah
toughen came out and I played that a bit
and that was really fun but I also have
a really good phone now thankfully to an
awesome event I got to work I got a new
phone out of it and that's changed my
life in terms of mobile gaming I get to
play all these really cool mobile games
too so I wouldn't be you know mad to see
a mobile game derive of anything that's
out right now
oh snap round three big body action
immediate burst he was like stop it just
get away from me I don't want it just
get in there yes Wow who named nice
sidestep
oh my god go join in the stream with the
streak it's okay I think she'll live I
don't think he's gonna finish this combo
boom oh yeah the bread you had to get
the counter hit it in time it's all good
that's gonna conclude the stream the
streak was axed but it's all get it was
super close all the match we've got like
closer and closer but yeah you guys
thanks so much for tuning in to the
stream today and thank you Jordan for
playing against everybody online thank
you for having me checking out story
mode with us and playing something like
it's computer all the good stuff guys go
check out Jordans review of this game
it's up now on GameSpot light I mean
sorry I'm GameSpot calm
this is GameSpot live and we'll be back
tomorrow same time 11:00 a.m. and yeah
that's it see you guys later bye bye
you